Last time...
Matt, what are you doing? Whoa-oh!
...Halloween came early in the tent.
I've decided to dress as Noel,
so I'm baking in heels.
While Syabira... I love it.
...left the judges spellbound...
Handshake. Thank you.
First in Technical,
great Showstopper.
Wow.
...claiming the Star Baker crown,
Kevin's cake...
Oh, man alive.
...was a horror show.
It does look a bit of a mess.
But Dawn's cat...
That is shocking.
..Was cursed.
Can't really taste anything.
And she was the sixth baker
to leave the tent.
One of the absolute best experiences
of my life.
Now... ls there such a thing as
too much custard?
No. No.
..It's Custard Week.
So I'm ready for you, ice cream.
With a Signature where no-one wants
to sink to the bottom...
Float the island.
Float, baby, float.
...a Technical with a timed twist...
What? What? What?
I just feel like I've been summoned
into a naughty tent.
...and a Showstopper...
I wish I had three arms, honestly.
...where the custard must hold
itself together...
It's quite wobbly.
It's super jiggly. Jiggle jiggle-
...as much as the bakers.
Oh, no.
The freezer is four degrees.
It's going to be melting.
But the thing is, there's so many
custard things you can make.
Everything. If you think,
there's a custard slice.
But they could even do
pain aux raisins again. No.
Last week was amazing,
I would say that.
I was wondering if I'm ever going
to be a Star Baker
and once I got it, I hope everyone
else will get it, as well.
It is Custard Week, so there
is a lot that can go wrong.
With confidence it's, uh,
it's in the mid ground
at the moment.
Custard, custard, custard, custard.
I kind of love making custard.
There's just so much you can do.
You get creme anglaise,
creme patissiere, creme au beurre.
I had no idea that there were so
many different varieties of custard.
Creme legere, creme chiboust,
creme mousseline.
I thought custard was just custard.
Bonjour, mes amis.
Welcome back to
le grand blanc... tente.
For your Signature challenge,
Paul and Prue would like you
to create your take on
the classic French dessert
iles flottantes.
The judges are looking
for eight perfect portions
of poached meringue floating on
a sea of silky smooth
creme anglaise.
The flavours are up to you.
The judges just want to see some
beautifully presented floaters.
You have an hour and a half.
On your marks. Get set.
Bake.
I never heard of floating
island before.
I heard about floaters a lot,
but not floating island.
The last time I had a floating
island is when I last practised this
and it was absolutely filth.
It's a bit of a funny one.
I like the custard, but I'm not
a fan of poached meringue.
Reminds me of baby food a bit.
It's Custard Week this week.
One of my favourite things
to eat ever.
Now, they've got
to make eight floating islands.
Basically they're a poached meringue
floating in English custard,
creme anglaise.
I normally buy custard,
because it's much easier to go
and get a 50p can, innit?
HE LAUGHS
So we want to see introduction
of colour, flavour and texture.
I'm just gonna make eight
little biscuits.
Lychee. Oh, they're like eyeballs.
I always like making
floating islands.
Silky smooth and light
and it melts in the mouth.
They are the most delicious.
So, how does it feel after
last week?
Did you get a handshake
and you won the Technical
and you won Star Baker?
That is actually
a very nice achievement,
but we're all back to
the clean slate this week. Wow.
Who are you? What are you doing now?
I'm making mojito cocktail,
actually. Mojitos.
Now you're talking my language.
Syabira's meringues will be coated
in a layer of sand crumble,
flavoured with mint leaves
and lime zest.
Her creme anglaise will be presented
in bowls painted
with palm trees
to complete her mojito islands.
Only a mojito lover can live in that
mojito island.
Everything that you serve will be
only mojito.
Mojito cake, mojito flavour,
mojito toast, mojito jam.
Rather than saying good morning,
you say mojito.
And if the judges need something
to sober them up after
Syabira's mojitos,
janusz has just the recipe for
the morning after.
I've decided to celebrate
my favourite morning drink,
vanilla latte.
So it's gonna be a... Oh, I thought
it was going to be Bovril. No!
So you've got coffee
in the custard.
Two espressos,
but it looks like latte.
Nice, OK.
Yeah, that's a really nice idea.
Janusz's floating island nods
to his perfect breakfast
with a coffee and
vanilla creme anglaise,
served alongside a bite-sized
marmalade-flavoured biscuit.
Is this the first time you've come
across it yourself?
I had it before in Poland.
We call it soup of nothing.
Soup of nothing?
Soup of nothing.
That's how a floating island
should be.
It should just disappear in
your mouth.
Yes.
Now I'm making the custard.
There's milk and double cream
in this.
I'm gonna then add
the orange zest and vanilla paste.
Not only are Paul
and Prue expecting
the creme anglaise
to be perfectly smooth...
I'll have lime and
rum creme anglaise.
The judges are gonna be smashed.
...they also want it to have
a perfectly balanced taste.
Rose can really easily become
an overpowering flavour.
I always stop just before I think
I should.
Ancl I'm just gonna add
some cardamom.
Sandro is taking it one step further
and going all out
with his flavour profiles.
I've not had that wow
with the flavours yet.
I've just had the,
"Oh, it tastes nice."
Which is great, but I want
that, like, oh-oh-oh-oh!
His flavours bring together
creme anglaise
with a cherry jelly,
chocolate shavings,
and a caramelised almond
and hazelnut topping.
Plus he's bringing in
a boozy element
to give the wow factor he's after.
The custard is going to
be brandy-infused
and then I've got cherry jelly
with a bit of rose prosecco in it.
Have you practised this?
I have practised it and I thought
it's just a bit too simple,
so I added the alcohol in it.
I'm just really trying
to make sure the flavours are all
well balanced.
Kevin's also adding a tipple
for the judges.
I've never tried popping prosecco
with a sword.
I normally just do it the safe way
with a towel over the cork.
But it's not the custard
he's adding it to.
The meringue will be flavoured
with prosecco and...
How much prosecco?
Eight tablespoons.
It'll deflate a bit, but as long as
you whisk it enough, it comes back.
Kevin's prosecco meringue
will float in a sea
of rose creme anglaise
topped with lychee
and raspberry coulis.
In keeping with the island theme,
his decoration will be
a tuile biscuit,
coloured pink
to look like tropical coral.
You could've done an island
you see in the middle of a loch.
Oh, that'd be too cliche.
Could've done Nessie.
A bit on the nose.
With Nessie sort of in there.
Nessie in the loch.
Hey, Matt, do you like my cake?
It's a Pac-Man cake.
Didn't Pac-Man have an eye?
Yeah, he had an eye, yeah.
Thanks. Thanks for your help. Yeah.
Dun-dun-dun-dun dun-dun-dun-dun.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Right, now I can pour it inside this
mixture of eggs and sugar.
Ancl then get it back in the pan
and then cook it until
it's thickened.
Custard needs to be cooked low
and slow to get
the consistency just right.
There's a lot that can go wrong.
The custard can be overcooked.
It could be undercooked, as well.
It's a process that cannot
be rushed.
You just need to keep on whisking it
until it's thickened. Strong arms.
Cook it too quick
and the eggs will scramble.
You mustn't boil it.
It shouldn't get above about
80, 85 degrees.
But remove it from the heat too soon
and it will not thicken enough
and the floating islands will sink.
This is taking years to thicken up.
I am quite patient,
but this is just...
just... just a bit too much.
Maxy's poached meringue will sit in
a lagoon of creme anglaise
and blueberry sauce.
It'll be topped with caramelised
sugar swirls and glitter dust.
I've seen people actually lose
years of their lives
stirring custard. Stirring away.
Thinking it's not gonna happen,
then suddenly it does happen.
Yeah, it does.
Ancl they get really excited.
Yeah.
Have you ever stirred custard, Matt?
I get the Bird's to do it.
See what I've done there.
It's a bit thicker.
Ancl I think we're clone.
It's looking good.
It's the right texture.
This is kind of done.
It looks really runny,
but it should be all right.
With their custards completed
and left to cool...
I'm gonna pop it in the fridge.
Uh, meringue.
Am I right or a MERINGUE?
...the bakers move on to making
the all-important meringue islands.
I'm making
the French meringue style.
So in this case I whisked my
egg whites to a soft paste.
Now I'm adding sugar.
Gradually.
Once it reaches stiff peaks
and all my sugar is there,
I will then shape them
and start poaching them in water.
Abdul's poached meringue
will be topped
with caramel swirls
and sit in an orange creme anglaise,
marbled with a cherry coulis.
Is this something
you've made before?
I had never even seen these before.
You're quite good
with meringue, though, aren't you?
My wife's made of meringue.
Uh-huh. Well, she was.
She's just an eggy liquid
in the bottom of a pan now,
but, you know.
Interesting. We still get on.
So, the show's been getting
a few letters of complaint that
we've been stressing
the bakers out a little bit
with our time calls
and that we need to be
a little bit more soothing. OK.
So I've been practising, OK...
OK.
...a kind of soothing time call.
Ready? Yes.
Bakers,
you have half an hour left.
Let's not panic just yet.
I'll do eight tablespoons
of prosecco.
It'll deflate a bit, but give it
a chance to whip back up.
Whipping the meringue to just
the right degree is crucial.
Stiff and glossy.
Not enough and it won't be firm
enough to hold its shape...
This is abstract art now.
...making it tricky to successfully
form identical floating islands...
just trying to get them
as same as possible.
...that will hold firm in liquid
for poaching.
It's gonna be a very generous
portion.
I don't want to be called
as a stingy lady.
I'm gonna pipe meringue
that's gonna look like latte foam.
But, yeah, my hands are literally,
like, shaking.
Have you been drinking? No!
Not for a long time now.
I'm gonna begin poaching,
so I'm gonna poach my meringues
in the milk.
Let's try the first one.
So I'm gonna poach them
for two minutes on each side.
Everyone will be poaching
their meringues in liquid.
Mine rely on steam,
because you will destroy
the piping.
My meringues have just gone wrong.
They're way too soft
and just totally collapsed.
It's like the Titanic.
In what way? Little icebergs.
Little mini icebergs. Oh, right.
I thought you meant
the tragic ending. No!
If you touch them on the outside
and they look good
and fluffy, it's almost ready.
At least that's what I think.
OK, that looks good.
This one is clone.
Floaters are clone. I'm happy.
What you looking at? I'm looking
at that magic over there.
Oh, yeah. I know.
Yours look like that.
Yeah, yeah.
These are not good.
They just look a bit rough.
Coat them in the minty sand.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
I'm going to start putting
the custard in.
Prosecco jelly has set.
It's a minty sand topped with
the creme anglaise.
Nice bit of retro kitsch
glassware.
Oh, this coffee smells good.
There we are, baby.
Ancl now I'm gonna jazz this up now.
This is my cherry coulis.
Right, meringues next.
They're very delicate things.
Float the island.
Float, baby, float.
I mean, they do float.
Oh, that's a sorry-looking one.
How long do I have left?
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Oh, boy.
Time pressure, time pressure.
Just the final decorations.
OK, so this is the raspberry
and lychee coulis.
Blueberry sauce.
Add the hazelnuts.
Oh, coraltuile is ready.
Final decorations.
Dunk 'em in.
Think I'm just rushing a bit.
This is looking messy!
My hands are literally shaking.
Too much coffee.
Oh, my God.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from
your floating islands.
Oh, that's cool.
They look like coated
breaded chicken.
Yeah. Isn't it?
Coated breaded chicken? What?
That's the last thing
I want to hear, Sandro.
SHE CHUCKLES
The bakers' floating islands
will now face
the judgement of Paul and Prue.
Hi, Syabira.
Hello, Syabira. Hi, hello.
I actually thought it was
a deep-fried chicken.
Yes, that's what Sandro was saying.
Sitting in a bechamelsauce.
That's delicious, as well.
I think it is a floating
desert island.
It's covered in sand.
It does look great.
It is a lime creme anglaise
topped with
the meringue,
coated with the minty sand.
As always, there's nothing wrong
with your flavours.
They're fresh,
they're very distinct
and your meringue
is beautifully poached.
It's a great mojito.
The custard is perfect.
It's the lime in that.
It's got that sharpness that
cuts through,
so it's not too sweet.
Very clever. Well clone, Syabira.
You're in some kind
of crazy groove.
They look nice.
They look quite attractive.
The meringue's lost its height
because of probably
the weight of the caramel.
You have orange custard.
Look at that custard.
And then we have a cherry coulis.
It is absolutely delicious.
It's very sweet,
but the custard's
an excellent flavour.
I love the orange. OK.
I'd like to have seen the meringue
a little bit more robust.
Looks quite appetising.
I'm not sure it's enough
for a dessert.
The combination of flavours
is really delicious.
The acidity of the puree sets off
the meringue's sweetness perfectly.
It's lovely. The blueberry's got
a lovely tartness to it.
But the creme anglaise could've been
a little bit thicker.
It's quite effective.
Looks like a latte.
Your creme anglaise texture
is absolutely perfect.
It's thick enough.
As a latte goes, it's delicious.
There's just enough coffee in there.
It's very delicate
and I love the flavour and texture.
It's delicious.
I mean, I'm really tempted
to keep going,
but I won't cos I've got more
to come. Thank you. Thank you.
I think it looks busy.
I do think they look quite
pretty though.
You have the cherry jelly,
bit of prosecco,
spiced custard with brandy.
Certainly got brandy in it.
It certainly has.
It's very alcoholic.
I think that the custard is perfect
from a texture point of view.
You'd have been better not to
have the prosecco in the jelly. OK.
Because the brandy's quite enough.
I think you got carried away.
Thank you. Thank you.
I think the puree, it's probably
slightly watered it down.
It's slackened off
the creme anglaise. Hmm.
The custard is smooth as anything.
I love the prosecco.
It's a lovely light mouthful,
but it does mean that the islands
are a bit squashed. Yeah.
The meringues have disintegrated
with the prosecco,
so the alcohol has broken
the meringue apart.
The lychee is delicious.
Mmm. Thank you.
That was another mixed one.
Bottom of a pretty good bunch
is an OK place to be.
Pauls aid it looks like
a chicken and bechamel,
but they said the custard was
perfect. I'm very pleased.
Too much going on.
It was too busy, which it was.
Game plan going into
the Technical
is I'm sitting at the back,
so I've got the whole view
to see what everyone else is doing.
HE LAUGHS
The bakers were able
to practise their floating islands,
but have no idea what awaits them
in the Technical challenge.
Well, bakers, it's time
for your Technical challenge,
which today has been set by
Prue be-doo-be-doo.
Prue be-doo, any words of advice?
Take your time and keep your cool.
That cannot be it.
That is it.
As ever, this Technical challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're going to have
to ask these two to hop it.
Go on, get out of here.
Don't want you round here.
For your Technical challenge,
we're gonna do something
a little bit different.
We're gonna have a staggered start
time and a staggered finish time.
What? What? What?
BLEEP just got real.
So could everybody leave
the tent except for Sandro.
What? Bye-bye.
No, but wait.
What is... going on?
No pressure.
The judges would like you
to make six pistachio
and praline ice cream cones.
Your cones should be dipped in
chocolate and nuts
and then topped with a pistachio
and praline ice cream.
You have two hours and 45 minutes.
On your marks. Get set.
Bake.
This is the most nervous I've felt.
Normally the other bakers are here,
so I get to sort of see
if I'm on the right track,
but today I'm all alone.
Pistachio and praline ice cream cone
for a Technical. This is a first.
It's Custard Week
and to make good ice cream, you need
to be able to make good custard.
I'd like there to be at least one
and a half scoops in there.
I always feel cheated when I get
a cone
that's just a little mound on
the top.
They have to make their own cones.
They should be golden brown,
not pale,
and of course if they're too dark,
they'll be too brittle.
Ancl you get that nasty burnt taste.
Slightly burnt taste.
One of the really tricky things
about this challenge
is the timing.
If they don't get their ice cream
frozen properly,
we are going to have pistachio soup.
Ancl we're doing staggered starts
to make it absolutely fair when
we're judging.
Shall we try, then, Prue?
Mmm. That is beautiful.
The cone is crispy.
Silky smooth ice cream.
The texture from
the praline inside is lovely.
It's really good, strong
pistachio flavour.
Even on a cold clay, Prue,
having ice cream, actually,
it doesn't really matter, does it?
I know. It tastes great. I know.
I've never even heard of
a custard ice cream.
I just know it needs to be frozen,
so gotta be pretty quick.
To begin with, it says
to make creme anglaise.
This is a mixture of double cream
and milk.
I'm gonna wait until it starts
to simmer,
which is already...
It's getting there.
Come join the party, baker two.
Come and join us.
The judges would like you
to make six pistachio
and praline ice cream cones.
You have two hours, 45 minutes.
On your marks. Get set.
Bake.
It is very empty and very quiet.
I think more or less I know what
I'm doing.
So I'm ready for you, ice cream.
These eggs will be creamed
with some sugar.
Ancl then mix that in.
Baker three,
would you like to join us?
Don't look so frightened. You're OK.
The judges would like you
to make six pistachio
and praline ice cream cones.
On your marks. Get set.
Bake.
This is weird.
Oh, I just feel like
I've been summoned into
a naughty tent.
Just like, "Oh, we've been naughty,
haven't we?"
Never made ice cream with custard.
I need to get this creme anglaise
to cool down as soon as I can.
That was weird, weren't it?
Yeah, it was strange
being the only person in here.
Have you made anything like
this before?
I've never made ice cream before.
It's not a thing, innit?
The ice cream man comes over
to your road
and he parks right in front of
the house, as well.
You don't go, "Sorry, love.
Sorry, love, we make our own."
We've made it already, yeah.
Hello, baker four.
On your marks. Get set.
Bake.
I don't know anything about
ice cream, to be honest.
I've got no idea. Clueless.
Let's just start.
The key is to keep an eye on
the custard when it's cooking,
so you don't get scrambled eggs.
So it needs to be cooked on
the stove until it gets thickened.
Baker number five.
On your marks. Get set.
Bake.
I've made ice cream before.
I've got an ice cream maker at home.
I can do this.
It's just like being at home.
I'm looking for my custard
to thicken up.
Until it's thick enough to coat
the back of a spoon.
I'm gonna do it a bit thicker than
I did the floating island custard.
Baker six, would you like
to join us?
On your marks. Get set.
Bake.
Yes. The last one in. So, this is
the first time I'm making ice cream.
This is the first time I'm seeing
this machine, so... let's see.
Creme anglaise is nearly ready.
I'm happy with the way it looks.
It's all a bit crazy. Yeah.
Staggered.
I know!
Maybe it's because of the ice cream.
They don't want it to get melted...
Yeah, that is it, I think.
...when the next judges...
It's quite breezy here, isn't it?
Yeah, it's very breezy.
It's like a gale.
I've made my creme anglaise.
It is looking pretty decent.
I'm quite happy with it.
It's gonna go to the ice bath.
So it's cool enough for
the ice cream machine.
The bakers need to reduce
the temperature
of their creme anglaise
as quickly as possible.
That's in the fridge.
In the fridge.
But where they cool it is crucial.
You can't put a hot creme anglaise
into the freezer.
The temperature difference,
it might cause a issue.
Into the fridge.
I chill in the freezer
to get it down as fast as I can.
Adding warm creme anglaise to
a freezer
will cause the freezer's
temperature to rise.
And now it can go to the freezer.
And may prevent the ice cream from
setting later in the challenge.
It's cooled, which is good.
Yeah, that's ready.
I am adding in my pistachio paste.
I'm gonna add the food colouring.
Pistachios shouldn't have too
much colour.
It says to churn and then to freeze.
When it gets really thick
and ice creamy,
I will turn it off,
however long that will take.
It'll probably take about 45 minutes
to churn. I don't know.
If this works out,
I'll be so proud of myself.
Right, now I'm gonna
make the...
...waffle cones.
I've got an idea of how it's clone.
I'm gonna whip up my egg whites,
then sift in the flour
and icing sugar,
fold in the butter.
That looks good.
It looks the right consistency.
I'll start cooking them now.
I'm gonna go for it.
I'm just gonna trust the press.
First one is in. Lid is on.
I give them two minutes
and wait patiently.
Pop it in for three minutes.
Five minutes, four minutes.
I just need this to be golden.
Three, two...
Hello.
Not there yet.
Yeah. I'm going for a goldeny type
colour and just roll it.
Not brown, just golden.
Once it's done, you just need to
roll straight away and let it set.
Tighter at the bottom.
Something is burning.
Something's burning.
Or is it me?
Oh, no!
Oh!
What?
Whoa-oh!
I just made an ice cream cone.
That's really cool. Ha-ha!
It's six, right?
I'll go again.
I'm going to do it for less time.
Well, that's better.
Ow! It's so hot.
Well, I definitely didn't
perfect it.
Look at that.
Hmm.
You ever clone that before?
I've never made
a waffle cone before.
So you just did that. I'm gonna be
obsessed with waffle cones now.
Yeah, are you getting
a waffle cone maker?
It feels fine.
Don't try that at home, children.
Burning, burning, burning.
I smell burning.
Whoa, man. They're burnt.
What is going on?
OK, even less time than that.
Final one.
Chicka-ching! Hot, hot!
That is six.
This one is OK. This one is OK.
I'm moving on to next step.
Make the praline.
Caramelise my sugar,
put it on top of the pistachios.
When I was a kid,
pistachio ice cream
was something you had on holiday.
Yeah.
On the Algarve. Sort of like,
"Ooh, ooh, they've got pistachio.
"Ooh, they've got pistachio!
"Ron, they've got pistachio.
Did you want pistachio?
"You like pistachio.
"No, just vanilla?
He just wants a vanilla."
It's getting there, baby.
I'm just gonna stop churning it.
It's pretty thick.
I think it's clone.
Scrape the ice cream into a bowl
and fold through the praline.
Freeze.
Make sure that's all in there.
And now it can go to the freezer.
So I need it to set quick,
quick, quick, quick, quick.
It's gonna freeze. Should be OK.
I will be leaving this in the
freezer for as long as possible.
Dip the ice cream cone rims
in melted chocolate,
then in chopped pistachios.
Pistachios on my wafer.
What I'm actually gonna do is put
some melted chocolate in. Yeah.
Ooh, yeah, I'm gonna put that
in there.
You just gonna do that?
I'm just gonna do it.
Like a little secret extra. Wow.
I hope my ice cream is freezing.
I'm gonna see my ice cream.
It's still soft.
It's set. I'm happy, happy.
The freezer is four degrees.
It's gonna be melting.
Ah, stress.
I'm praying really hard silently
so my ice cream sets.
Baker number one,
you have five minutes until judging.
It's cold.
Everything's cold right now.
How many scoops do they want?
I'll try and do two.
Then I've just got to drizzle
chocolate sauce.
I'm gonna do it in the freezer,
the rest of this.
A little bit of the sauce.
Baker number two,
you have five minutes.
Baker number one,
I am coming to get your bake now
for judging.
Happy?
Sir, madam.
These look quite attractive.
They've managed
to get two balls on.
I mean, the green's about right,
as well, the colour.
And the cone is absolutely lovely.
It's crisp. Mmm.
I can't hear anything.
It's nice and creamy,
the ice cream, and set.
The baker has filled
the inside with... With chocolate.
"Chocolate. It stops
the ice cream soggying it up.
That is delicious.
My ice cream didn't set.
It's so hard, mate.
It's like water.
Baker number three,
you have five minutes left.
Baker number two,
I'm coming for you.
Thank you.
That looks like it's been in
the sun for six hours,
pouring out the bottom hole.
The cone seems to be crisp enough.
The praline's good.
It's a good flavour,
but it's just not set.
The freezer didn't cool down
my ice cream. It's melting.
I feel like I want to give up
this challenge.
If it melts, it melts.
I did my best.
Baker number three,
I'm coming to get your bake
right now.
Thank you. Thank you.
Ah, it's just melting.
I'll get it there quick.
There you go.
It's very soft. It's not set.
It's just like liquid.
Oh. Mmm. Oh!
It's leaking all over,
even down the side.
Because the ice cream is so unset,
the praline doesn't have
the proper crunch it should. No.
A sort of pistachio soup.
It's fine.
It seems fairly stable.
I was going to do a second scoop
on top, but don't think I will.
Baker number four, your time is up.
Well, the ice cream looks set.
Try a little bit of that cone.
Mmm, the ice cream tastes nice.
Very crunchy praline.
Shame we didn't get
the second scoop.
That's a mean ice cream.
Delicious, but not enough.
I wonder if the ice cream's
a bit on the soft side.
I'm just trying to keep it neat.
Baker number five,
I'm coming for your bake right now.
Happy?
Down to the wire.
The most obvious problem
immediately is that
the chocolate is just
a great ugly lump on top. Yeah.
The wafer's good, good texture.
You do get a little bit of praline.
The ice cream mix itself is good.
It is melting very, very quickly.
It's melting very quickly. Eeesh.
It feels weird,
like everyone is watching me.
Baker number six, your time is up.
Thank you. Thank you.
The wafer looks a little too dark
and too brittle.
They're over baked.
The ice cream is nice
and smooth.
It's just melting pretty
quickly now.
Paul and Prue will now rank
the ice creams from worst to best.
In sixth spot, we have this one.
Syabira.
Ice cream wasn't set.
In fifth place, we have this one.
Janusz. It wasn't set, was it?
Abdul is fourth
and Kevin third.
In second, we have this one.
Maxy, these are pretty good.
You needed to put more ice cream
on it to create a bigger dome.
Which means we have this one.
Sandro, absolutely delicious.
Nothing wrong with it at all.
I feel great.
I got my first Technical win.
They still taste great.
They are just more sort
of smoothie than an ice cream.
It's terrible. Disappointed.
There's always a rainbow
after the rain.
Let's do this. Four more hours.
Happy Custard Week, everybody.
Custard Week. I love custard.
Who'd have thought it?
Coming from northern stock,
anything with custard is good.
You can't just claim custard
from the north, you know that? Yeah.
There's a little village just
outside Bolton... Here we go.
...called Custard and that
is where it all came from. Really?
No, don't be ridiculous.
Of course not.
You had me there.
We've whittled down
to six really strong bakers now.
It's getting harder and harder,
isn't it?
Syabira did really well in
the Signature. Yeah.
But she was last in the Tech.
Whereas Sandro didn't do too well
in the Signature with what he did,
but he won the Tech.
So you've got these two
sort of jumping around.
Ancl then you look at everybody else,
they're all again smack in
the middle.
Ancl now you're in this position
where any challenge
you make one mistake, you could go.
Which is harsh, isn't it?
Bake Off is tough. It's brutal.
Oh, I can't bear it.
I wouldn't watch it. It's brutal.
Or be involved in it.
I'd wipe it off my CV.
Good morning, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent
for your Showstopper challenge.
Today Paul and Prue would
like you to bake
an exquisitely-decorated
set custard gateau.
Your gateau must consist
of multiple baked layers
and be sandwiched
and supported
by beautifully-flavoured,
perfectly set custard.
You can make any style
of gateau you like,
but the set custard elements must be
the star of the show.
I thought Paul Hollywood was
the star of the show?
Used to be. Now it's set custard.
Imagine being usurped
by set custard.
Oh, it's a tough business.
You have four hours.
On your marks.
Get perfectly set.
Bake.
This bake here, I need this
to be, like, perfection.
It's gonna be my, like,
do I get my Star Baker?
It's a personal favourite,
so I'm really excited to make this
and I hope the judges like it.
We've had pouring custard,
we've had frozen custard,
so for the Showstopper,
we're going to have set custard.
So, obviously there's many different
types of custard.
Creme pat, creme diplomat,
creme mousseline.
There has to be baked elements
in there.
There are so many different avenues
they could go down.
So, strawberries, I need 400 grams.
I'm gonna just reduce them.
Well, there are lots of ways
to set custard.
Most people would use flour
and a bit of gelatine.
It needs to be silky and soft,
but it must be firm.
So that when you get a slice,
it doesn't just bulge out.
I am thinking about
texture, flavour,
texture and flavour.
Ancl time.
Custard gateau has
to look amazing.
Lots of flavour,
lots of colour,
but custard has
to remain the hero.
Morning, Syabira.
Hello, Syabira.
Morning, hello. Hello.
Tell us about your custard gateau.
I'm making pina colada
custard cake today.
You see, there's
a theme going on here.
We're getting mojitos,
we're getting pina coladas.
It is a cocktail week this week.
Both Noel and I are big fans of
pina colada.
Paul always buys me pina coladas
when we go out. No pressure.
Syabira's cocktail gateau will
feature delicate pineapple flowers,
a coconut rum creme legere
and alternate layers
of pineapple creme pat
and rum sponge with
a tropical ingredient.
I'm adding the coconut milk inside
now to give
the coconut taste in the sponge.
I'm excited,
because I tried this cake alongside
a proper pina colada drink.
Pina colada, cake,
pina colada, cake,
pina colada, cake.
This is myjoconde sponge.
It's an almond-based sponge.
It's nice and moist.
The bakers want baked elements
to be both light enough
to avoid compressing
the silky set custard...
I'm making a traditional
Polish sponge.
It has both flour
and potato starch.
It brings the lightness
to the sponge.
...and firm enough
to structure their gateau.
I am going to make
a coconut sponge,
so it's more robust.
While most bakers are using sponges
to support their custards...
just starting my dough now,
so I'll start laminating it shortly.
...Abdul has been inspired
to do things differently.
So I'm basically making
a Mille-feuille.
Oh, nice.
So tell us about the puff pastry.
So I tried a rough puff pastry.
I'm actually using your recipe.
Oh, you'll do well with this.
You're gonna go far, Abdul.
Do you know...
What a move from Abdul.
Actually, that recipe is,
I think, as good as a puff pastry.
Yes. That's what I noticed,
as well.
I did notice there's a slight...
What is happening here?
What's happening here?
Can we just have a moment for this?
Abdul's Mille-feuille will be made
with layers
of compressed rough puff pastry
that will sandwich chocolate
creme patissiere
and vanilla creme diplomat,
along with strawberries,
raspberries and caramelised peaches.
But even with Paul's recipe on
his side, he needs to keep his cool.
In this weather, what you do is you
incorporate grated frozen butter
to add between the layers
and laminate them.
Oh, my hands are, like, freezing.
Frostbite.
Right, this needs to be in
the oven, like, asap.
So, they're gonna go to
the oven only for 20 minutes,
because they are just small
little cakes.
This will go in
for about 25 minutes.
So, pastry is gonna be in
the fridge
to chill for about 20,
25 minutes.
I'll start making my custard.
I'm currently mixing together
cornflour, eggs and caster sugar.
As the bakers move on
to their custards...
You just need to stir it patiently.
I'm making set custard.
It's really quick and easy to make.
...Sandro is chancing
a different method.
I'm doing it through the microwave.
How? Explain.
It'll go in to microwave for about
30 seconds at a time
until it thickens.
So rather than using a pan,
you decided to use a microwave?
Yeah. How do you feel about
the meecro-wavay, Paul?
If it works, it works.
Sandra's ambitious three tiers will
consist of three different custards,
a vanilla layer,
a coffee layer and a mango layer.
It'll be decorated
with butter cream roses
all in memory
of a very special person.
I wanted to do a tribute
to my friend that I lost.
She was, like,
helping me get on here.
I didn't even want to get on here,
really, like at the time.
What, and she encouraged you to...?
She wanted me to join the show.
Really?
Yeah. She would've loved
a cake like this for her birthday.
Well, she'd be very proud
of how you've done.
Yeah, she will be super proud.
Sandra's Showstopper isn't
the only one
to be inspired by someone special.
The Showstopper is a tribute
to my father-in-law who passed away.
He would've been really proud
to hear that I'm in the tent.
I just never got the chance
to let him know.
Maxy's gateau will feature exotic
layers of coconut
and almond dacquoise,
joconde sponge,
a lime and passion fruit curd
and a cascade of tropical fruits,
all set in place with
a more traditional filling.
I am making a creme pat.
Classic vanilla.
I want to keep it simple.
This is supposed to be about
the custard.
Yeah. Mm-hmm. It's gonna be
the hero, the custard, isn't it?
Yeah.
Some bay leaves,
some thyme to infuse
with my honey custard.
The judges are looking for custards
with perfectly-infused flavours.
I'm putting in pineapple
and lime.
I hope this will taste
exactly like a pina colada.
This is my chocolate
raspberry custard.
Janusz is taking his flavour
inspiration
from a favourite holiday.
So, I'm whisking Neapolitan set
custard gateau.
It's gonna consist
of three different custards.
Janusz's trio of custards will
comprise of
a dark chocolate
and raspberry custard,
a strawberry and ruby
chocolate custard,
and a white chocolate
and vanilla custard.
Keeping to his Italian theme,
he is soaking
his sponges in limoncello
and finishing off his cake
by decorating
with a white chocolate drip.
Have you practised?
I did practise, and I baked it in
high heels, as well.
You baked it in high heels?
Yes, just to make sure that
I can walk in those shoes that I had
for Halloween Week.
So that was me, 6 a.m. in my kitchen,
in my high heels.
In your high heels.
You know, I just feel like
there are too many rules in
this tent, you know.
It's really important that
the bakers get
to express themselves, you know.
Um, so, with that in mind,
bakers,
take as much time as you like
and bake whatever you want.
Paul won't like that.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
I'm taking them out of
the oven now.
The other cake is ready.
I am. I'm really happy with them.
Pop these in the freezer
so they cool quickly.
I've got one and two.
The puff pastry will try to rise,
but the trays above will
compress it.
I need the custard to be
a bit thickened.
I'm using gelatine, fully.
The consistency of
the custard is key
to a successful gateau.
Gonna go into the microwave
for about 30 seconds at a time
until it thickens.
And making the perfect silky
but firm custard
involves careful timing.
It's a bit grainy.
Like, usually it's very smooth.
Maybe it's the cornflour that
I didn't mix in properly.
I'm gonna make it again
just to be safe.
Thicken it too much and the custard
will be gloopy to eat.
See how set this custard is?
It's just right. Ooh.
But under cook it...
I'm a bit worried about this.
...and it could be a sloppy mess.
It's not thickening up.
At home, it would've been done
by now.
The pan's not very hot.
Have you had the wrong one on?
No, no, I haven't.
This is the right one.
Well, it's not very hot...
...at all. That's why.
It should be quite soft
when you slice into it.
That is a big bowl of custard.
I feel like I could jump into that.
Believe it or not,
we'll use pretty much all of it.
Really? Aye. Well, it's a set
custard gateau.
There needs to be...
You need a lot of custard.
...a lot of custard. Yeah. Ls there
such a thing as too much custard?
No. No.
Kevin's immense three litres
of custard
will be decked with nectarines
and raspberries upon
a dacquoise base.
The gateau will be topped
with raspberry jelly
and finished with
a cascading swirl
of Swiss meringue butter cream,
prosecco-infused macarons,
and bay leaves.
The thyme going in there's
going to be interesting... Hmm.
...to see how that works.
And the bay.
And bay, as well. And the bay.
Have you practised this at home?
Yeah, uh-huh. And when it comes to
the setting times for each layer,
have they managed to work OK?
Yeah, yeah they worked OK.
Ah. I'm setting the custard
with gelatine.
So it's like that,
it's just stacked? Yeah.
I think it sounds absolutely
wonderful
and I hope you pull it off.
So do I. Thank you.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
I wish I had three arms, honestly.
Or maybe eight, like an octopus.
I'm behind, because I had to make
one of my custards again.
I'll try to catch up as much
as possible.
While some bakers are waiting
for their custards to set...
It's going in the fridge.
...others are ploughing ahead
and assembling their gateau
with unset custard.
The hot custard needs
to be set together with the cake
so that it gels together.
I'm just putting the dark chocolate
and raspberry custard in.
And then a thick layer of custard.
Working with unset custard
makes it easier to create
the generous layers
the judges are looking for.
The custard layers are about
this thick.
Similar.
They wanted exactly
the same layers of custard to cake.
But deeper layers of custard...
Add another layer.
...require a longer setting time...
It's a lot of custard.
...to ensure a sturdy Showstopper.
It goes to the freezer!
Fridge. I need to let it set as
quick as I can.
Hopefully it will set on time.
You can see, like, it's not fully,
fully brown yet,
but it's only brown on the edges,
so, yeah,
maybe I'll just take it out now.
I hope this cools as instantly
as possible.
Syabira, we need to let
the bakers know
that they've got half an hour
left. Can you...? Mm-hmm.
Can you tell them all,
but in Malay, please?
Bakers, you have...
You all speak Malay, right?
It's an international language,
isn't it? Exactly.
Definitely not enough time,
but we'll try.
Press speedy mode on.
It's time to assemble now.
So now I'm getting the layers of
the coconut and mango clone.
I'm now spreading the hero of
the show, my custard.
It is ready now.
So to add some support,
I added raspberries.
Set.
Definitely not set yet.
How do you think this bake is going?
Do you think you're on schedule?
I'm a bit behind, because I had
to make my custard again.
It was grainy and I was like,
"You know what?
"Paul Hollywood will
notice that."
And I didn't want...
He'll put you in custurd-y.
Yes, he will put me in custody.
My passion fruit and lime curd.
That joke was a TRIFLE corny.
Orangey Madeira-type sponge
with vanilla custard.
I am so scared to open it.
But I've touched it
and it's pretty soft.
I'm still just waiting for
the custard to set.
I'm hoping it'll set quite quickly.
It's super jiggly. Jiggle jiggle.
Now I'm assembling the joconde
sponge with the coffee custard.
Bakers, you have
15 minutes remaining.
Cakes.
- You can do it.
So, this is the peach layer.
Pipe with butter cream.
Let's do this, like, ruthless.
I'm gonna coat them with
white coconut rurn.
Creme legere. Creme legere is
a whipped custard cream.
That looks nice. Can I drink that?
Yeah, you can.
Maybe I'll just pour it over
my feet.
That's a custard treatment.
Custard treatment?
It's actually good,
because all the sugar,
all the butter,
it's actually moisturising.
I haven't had a custard treatment
for a while, have you?
No, never.
Just set.
As long as it's set inside.
Would you like me to...?
I'll just turn it. How do I do it?
You're gonna try
and pipe in there, all right?
I'm cake boarding
and dowelling every layer.
Yeah, come on, strong.
All right, all right, all right.
Come on, Matt. We ain't got time.
Pipe really hard. I'm doing it!
Oh, like that. Oh, like that.
All right. There you go, yeah.
It's quite wobbly.
Let's go, go, go, go,
go! Go! Go! Go, go,
90, go, go, go, go, go,
Done. Look at that.
I made a cake!
That's not stable.
Right, if you get Star Baker,
I want a cut.
I'm sharing it with you. Yeah.
I'll give you 5%. Yes, please.
All right.
Oh, no.
Not cool, not cool.
The dowels aren't keeping it
stable enough.
I'm gonna present it on two stands.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
I'm getting stressed out.
This is the vanilla custard now.
If I'm making a cake,
there will be drip on it.
Hopefully the flavour is
pina colada.
Really pretty purple roses
and rosettes.
The dried pineapple is gonna be
like a flower.
Neapolitan ice cream.
Trying to decorate as much
as possible.
I'm very pleased with how it
turned out. I need more time.
Do you need any help?
I'm trying to pipe that all over.
Just, uh... I can't stop thinking
of my friend though, now.
You pipe, we pile.
It's three of us. Come on.
I'm getting a bit overwhelmed.
It's a very jiggly cake, babes.
I know.
I'll go and help Kevin.
Mmm. Yum, yum, yum.
I know. We've got ten seconds.
What do you wanna do?
Some nectarines.
Bakers, your time is up.
Oh, that'll do, that'll do.
Yeah, that's it, that's it.
Please step away from your bakes.
Well done, everybody.
Sandro, how did you manage this?
Uh...
You need to tell me what kind
of witchcraft you used inside.
Witchcraft.
Because that is crazy next level.
It's judgement time
for the bakers' showstopping
set custard gateau.
Abdul, would you like to bring up
your Showstopper, please?
It looks absolutely lovely, Abdul.
It looks very professional.
Quite stylish.
Let's have a look, shall we?
We have raspberry
and chocolate creme pat,
vanilla creme diplomat
with caramelised peaches.
That big enough for you, Prue?
Now, what are you trying
to tell people?
Right...
Paul, you greedy man.
The custard in both layers
is definitely the hero.
I think the texture of
the custard's perfect.
The pastry needed longer
in the oven. OK.
Probably needed another five minutes
just to get a bit of colour as well
more than anything else.
But overall, I like the textures
and the flavours.
I think you've got the idea of
a Mille-feuille spot on.
Thank you. Really good job.
Well clone, Abdul. Well done.
Thank you.
It looks impressive.
I like the variety of colours
in the piping.
I think it looks lovely, and then...
And the drip, drip.
Obviously the drip.
The drip is perfect.
There's a chocolate
and raspberry custard,
there is a ruby chocolate
and strawberry custard,
and a white chocolate
and vanilla custard.
The proportion of custard
to sponge is good.
Sponges are nice.
All the custards are too gloopy
and too dense,
too thick on the mouth.
It's not fresh enough.
I would've thought all those
flavours would be very fresh.
The custard's more like
wallpaper paste.
Don't mince your words, then.
It is.
Thank you.
I don't know whether it's formal
or informal.
I don't know whether it's messy
or very attractive or artistic.
I'm not quite sure how
to look at it.
Yeah, I'd say it's slightly messy
and really attractive.
It's eclectic.
Wow. Wow, look at that.
Look at that.
I think your flavours are great.
Your sponges are good.
However...
...I'm not sure it celebrates
custard and makes it the hero.
This is a beautiful cake.
The sponge is perfect.
The icing's lovely.
The problem is this was supposed
to be about set custard.
There's very little custard
and none of it is set.
Thank you, Maxy.
Thank you, Maxy. Well clone, Maxy.
Thank you.
It is a pina colada custard cake.
Well, I think it looks amazing.
It is so unusual.
You actually coated it with custard.
It's much easier to just slap
butter cream all over it.
It's just fantastic.
Wobble-icious.
Oh, my goodness.
Wow. The amount of custard in that.
It's great, isn't it?
That's what it's meant to be
and it's set.
That custard gateau is impressive.
I've never had one with
so much custard in it
and be that stable.
The lime that comes through,
the pineapple and then your coconut.
I think the whole thing together
is just spectacular.
And the other thing
that's impressive about
so much custard is that
it's not too gluey
and it's not rubbery.
I mean, you've just hit it right.
Look at the wobble on that.
I know. Like a jelly.
Well clone, Syabira.
Well done. Well clone.
Smashed it.
Syabira.
I think it looks great. Very neat.
The piping is absolutely exquisite.
It's both bold and modern
and yet very creative.
So, the bottom tier sponge
is coconut
and you've got the mango custard.
Well done.
The second tier in the middle
is a joconde sponge with
a coffee custard
and the top tier is
a... orange sponge with
a vanilla custard.
I think the bottom one's a triumph.
It's clever.
The coconut mango is nice.
Mmm, I love it.
That is a wonderfully light sponge.
The coffee,
the sponge is really good.
The coffee custard's
a bit glutinous, dry.
OK.
I think every one
of those cakes is highly sale able,
absolutely delicious
and would be gobbled up by anybody.
Well done. Well clone.
Thank you.
Shall I bring this back?
Thank you. Thanks. Thanks, mate.
Well done.
Kevin, would you like to bring up
your set custard gateau
Showstopper?
Do you want a hand?
Yeah, please.
Have we had an earthquake?
Wow, it's literally just...
...dropped as it's opened right up.
Yeah.
Right, let's have a look at the...
See if we can get a slice.
So what we have here is
a dacquoise sponge
topped with honey,
thyme and bay set custard.
Topped with raspberry jelly.
Do you know,
that custard is amazing?
It's so unusual.
The more you have it in your mouth,
the nicer it is,
and it goes beautifully with
the raspberries.
The thyme and the bay is amazing.
It works really well together.
It is delicious.
It's a shame that it looks a mess.
Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you.
Well done. Well clone.
They were ever so nice about
the flavours.
They were really,
really nice about it.
You know, if there's
a bit of hope there, I'll take it.
I feel like I made my friend proud.
I hope I'm in the chance
for Star Baker.
You just never really, really know.
I think Syabira clone a really good
job with her Showstopper.
It is just unbelievable.
I'm just like,
"Did I really make that?"
I feel like I'm just standing there
and I'm accepting it,
but at the same time,
I feel like, 0h,
I nearly melt down to the floor,
cos it's just too much
to handle.
That didn't went as well
as I planned.
I've made a gloopy custard.
Definitely that puts me in
the bottom,
so it's up to the judges.
Well... That was a lot of custard.
Yes.
Or not, in some cases. No.
Janusz was disappointing.
It wasn't only that his custard
didn't taste great,
they were gluey and spreadable.
You said wallpaper paste. Yes.
How do you even know?
Ancl why have you been eating
wallpaper paste?
Shall we talk about Kevin?
The flavour were essentially
the best ones in the tent.
They were amazing.
What, thyme and bay?
But unfortunately, the stability of
the whole gateau
was not strong enough
and it just collapsed.
If they were set,
they were often gloopy,
and if they weren't set,
they tasted nice.
You have to get it just right,
and I'll tell you who did,
and that was Syabira.
She really triumphed, didn't she?
She had thick custard,
the flavours were terrific.
It looked great.
The design was just so modern.
What about Sandro?
He did a lot of work, didn't he?
He's always ambitious.
I think two of those cakes
were pretty well perfect.
The bottom layer, the mango,
stunning.
Who do you think is in trouble?
I think Kevin, andjanusz is also
in line to go home.
I can't believe that aboutjanusz.
It tasted awful.
Well done, bakers.
That was a tough week.
There were some very
impressive bakes,
but there can only be one
Star Baker
and the Star Baker this week is...
Syabira.
Thank you, guys. Thank you.
OK, that leaves me with
the horrible job
of announcing the person who will be
leaving us this week.
Ancl you're such
a small little gang now.
This is going to be horrible.
The person who's leaving us this
week is...
Kevin.
Sorry.
Well clone, Kevin. Thank you.
I'm nothing but proud.
The imposter syndrome's real and...
...coming into this competition
I didn't feel like I deserved
my place, but...
I feel like I can count myself
as one of this talented bunch.
Like... Oh, my...
That custard is just extraordinary.
I'm very sad to see Kevin go,
but that custard will remain with me
for the rest of my life.
I'm going to go home and do it.
I think he's invented something
wonderful.
Syabira got Star Baker again
because that was
a proper custard gateau.
She just smashed it
on every single department.
Aren't you a clever girl? Thank you.
Thank you. Twice.
I wouldn't have imagined I would get
a Star Baker.
Second in a row, that's wild.
It's one crazy journey that I had
this week.
Honestly, insane.
A little bit sad I didn't get
Star Baker,
cos I thought, like,
I was pretty close.
I'm feeling good to be back
for another week.
Oh, yeah, we're through to
the quarter-finals, innit? Yeah.
OK, I'm through to
the quarter-finals.
Whoo!
Next time...
What is this, mate?
...it's the quarter-finals.
I think it's cooked.
Pastry Week.
Oh, that is horrible.
The bakers must perfect
their puff...
I don't want to present raw pastry!
...for a super sweet Signature...
This is crazy, man.
...tackle a tongue-twisting
Technical...
Man-get-out.
Mange-ay tout.
...and create a showstopping
storybook of pies.
I'm expecting nothing
but perfection.